the show is just so fascinating to watch
I have to say one of the most
fascinating things is the relationship
that your characters have with that like
developing that both on screen and off
screen
dream-come-true is beautiful really you
know we ain't knocking I could speak for
Octavia it's all about finding good
material something that's on the page
something that sort of challenges you as
actors and and these characters is just
so rich and you're not really sure so
the secrets that they may be hiding and
just their family dynamics and it was it
was beautiful I mean I've been such a
huge fan of hers for so long and I've
known her for so long and to be able to
go toe-to-toe with this one my god it
does it just does not get better than
that and so it's uh really you know a
dream come true yeah definitely a dream
come true because you know TV series you
know when you're with a person for such
a an extended amount of time it's a
marriage so you I want to be married to
the right person I need to yes but he
was such a wonderful partner I mean
aside from you know his artistry and and
the everything he did to create Warren
you know you were so amazing to be
opposite of with the crew never
complained I mean he was also you were
at the end of it you were working on El
Camino it just never complained always
game to play and and just see where the
scene took it was wonderful
Octavia you've obviously had a little
bit of a good streak lately with your
producing projects how has that
transition been for you from you know
just into producing well I've been
here's the thing I'm now getting more
credits as a producer but I mean the
minute I
had five cents to option material I
started optioning things because I knew
there would come a day that I would get
to like spend other people's money and
let them realize I might be okay at
spending your money I'm gonna be good
with it but you know so it hasn't been
that much of a transition because it's
just always I've done it a lot on a lot
of projects but I've never asked for
credit but the most generous person to
offer me a credit because I was of
course you know saying you know we
should do this we should do this was
Forest Whitaker and Nina yang Bon Jovi
on fruitful station they offered me an
executive producer credit because you
know some people get that as a vanity
thing if you see my name on as executive
producer you know there's some work
involved but I've always been like you
know doing something behind the scenes
but I'm grateful last question how is
Octavia as a as a boss I mean the best
is she walks onto set and people don't
cower you know they just are so excited
that this and I've said this before but
this beacon of light that you really
just feel blessed to be a showered in
and she's just you know people love her
and I mean you can tell she's just so
positive and so humble and she just
loves she feels you know she knows she
feels very blessed and don't think
anything for granted yeah yeah it's
beautiful
you